but uh
so uh i don't know i was here all day
yesterday almost you know the talks and
uh it's supposed to be a conference on
algorithms and all bounds but i think
there was no
talk directly aimed at the connections
between algorithms and doorbells so
maybe there'll be
subsequent uh talks uh
uh when i talk to the organizers they
asked me to give some general uh
something general about this connection
between low bars and
algorithms and i started preparing this
kind of uh
talk but then as usual you know you are
much more excited about what you are
doing
currently so that's what i really will
really tell you about
and just to uh pay my dues to the
organizers and my promise
i'll do five minutes flash of
connections of algorithms and low bounds
and i think actually this may be a good
thing to elaborate on in
you know the panel tomorrow something
like that but anyway so
don't expect to get anything from that
uh
okay the main thing i learned about the
connection between algorithms and romans
i learned as a postdoc
and this is this message you cannot
prove higher lower bonds than what your
algorithms
do that's how barrington discovered this
famous theorem he was trying to prove
low bounce on concern with bunch of
programs for majority and he discovered
that they can do all of nc1
so that's the main this you have to
remember this but this is a great
connection right because
when you're working on one you're
working on the other
uh there are a lot of connections i
wrote down a few
in both directions you know some
algorithms that give lower bounds and
lower bounds that give algorithms
and sometimes it goes both ways uh
so i'll just flash them you know all of
them
during this diagonalization is a prime
example
uh in diagonalization in general of how
you use an algorithm in order
to prove bounds uh this is the kind of
thing that
uh you know we are not satisfied with
right we we know that p is sandwiched
between
l and p space but if we have a log space
algorithm for p
then we separated it from p space but
sometimes you can push it further than
this trivial
one and the even non-uniform algorithms
can imply
uniform separations this is the result
with the valentine and russell
uh you have a circuit simulations of uh
non-deterministic exponential time
proofs uh
actually uh uniform separation of course
it's actually by reduction to a trivial
thing like that
you prove that this uniform upper bound
is a uniform
and a non-union form algorithm implies a
uniform algorithm
which is the heart of the matter
actually i saw that
ryan williams in his survey and
algorithms and lower bounds recommend
that you read
this proof so i would join his
recommendation it's really weird
uh that there is this equivalence anyway
uh the approximation method is a very
different
way in which algorithms implied low
bandwidth has both
message uh to us about monotone circuits
or c02 circuits
that you you have a weak model what you
try to do
is actually approximate the functions
computes but
by a much much weaker motor muscle
and for this very weak model you of your
robots really
similar things happen of course with
random restrictions and so on
uh ryan williams took this idea
pushed it away
further how you use algorithms to on
weak models to prove lower bounds
and of course we have the amazing
connection
of valentin and russell that
polynomial identity tests some you know
very basic the randomization task
algorithm gives us low amounts and they
go in the other way also
uh although fewer i think
uh we have all the randomization uh
results you have a heart function
i remember i was a graduate student when
this happened and it
totally blew my mind that you can maybe
that's the first really
real example you take a lower bound for
something
and you get an upper bound for something
else a deterministic algorithm for some
problem uh there are more sophisticated
examples
even you know very recent there's this
beautiful lower bound of calling rats
separating information complexity and
communication complexity
what algorithm does it give
it shows that there is no direct sum in
communication complexity
this means it's an algorithm it's
algorithm that achieves economy of scale
you can save
ma you can compute many independent
copies of a function much
faster than their number of times
one so it's a very indirect beautiful
algorithmic
consequence of a low bound uh
we are compression and of course there
are natural proofs so
you know the
low bound proofs that we know of seem to
produce algorithms
it's a psychological statement we cannot
prove low bonds without
as a byproduct produce algorithm
okay so i leave you that there's lots of
things to discuss and find
generalizations of this and so on i want
to talk about
something else uh
i want to talk about uh attempts to find
lower bounds particularly
non-commutative lower bounds
we didn't get there we got to some
polynomial identity test in the
non-commutative
regime but the real story is not about
the result
which i think is very interesting but
actually about
these connections between so many fields
so this problem the particular
uh non-commutative identity test i'll
talk about connects all these things
connect them non-severely
many people have worked in these
different fields have worked on this
problem
for their own reasons often unaware of
various progresses in in others and
i want to tell you about some of this so
this is the
thing that we learned over the past two
years one work with
pavel and what i want to tell you about
today work with
two students in uh berkeley and pete
garg and
rafael oliveira so how
you know how do i demonstrate this
uh i can give you some of the references
that go into this picture
and i color coded them so you'll see
algorithms
you'll see low bounds you'll see
non-commutative algebra you'll see
algebraic geometry and invariant theory
and you'll see some
quantum information theory here so i'll
i'll skip this you don't have to
remember it
um what is this oh these are the
connections
okay so i will tell you about the
connection it took me two days to
generate this picture
but i didn't think that ah i see i
thought it would also so
this is a journey okay so these are the
things i want to tell you about
remember step by step yeah so there are
20 steps here
yeah which eventually get here so
actually
if i need the boat so maybe you can
switch this off
so it took me really two days to
lay out this thing so to minimize edge
lengths and crossings and
this was the hardest thing so uh
let me start of course i i want to have
this a two hour talk
so
and i don't have two hours and let's
pause there
i'll tell you about some of the things
and they will see the rest
uh you can ask me separately or
if we write up this is working progress
so
if we write the finish writing the paper
i hope to do some decent
survey of these connections
so there are several ways to a process
and
one is the other question
one is the sort of about uh sacred cows
and
i know slaughtering sacred cows uh
so who who invented the the standout
you know polynomial determine you know
identity
testing symbolic determinant let me
write it down sorry
you know so you have a a matrix i'll
call it
l of uh you know lij
for variables some variables that say
it's an n by n matrix
variables
you can might as well be n variables it
doesn't matter whether it's most n
squared then will be
up to polynomial n so you want to know
yeah no whatever in this uh
in this form find an algorithm for this
problem it's edmonds in 67.
and uh actually maybe i should start
writing down some of the fields we are
going to
talk about so there are algorithms
and this will include some
of course optimization even method
theory and then are algebra
complexity by complexity i mean some of
the fields i want to connect my
complexity of course there will be low
bounds
and the randomization
and completeness will be very important
and then i want to talk about some of
the
non-commutative algebra
very difficult algebra if you just write
alg alg looks like algorithm and
determinant deterministic you cannot
shorten to that it's a real problem
so here mainly the theory of skill
fields
and also what determinant means
uh and i want to talk about environment
theory
maybe in variant theory
and this you know maybe algebraic
geometry
and the yeah presentation theory and
stuff like that
um and i said i'll talk about quantum
information theory
and there are other fields there which i
will not get to ah so that's uh
it's very interesting you don't see the
boxes i was sure that we will see all
the box
do you see all the boxes yeah okay
well i'm not sure you have to look in
the boxes but
i think here you can see me pretty well
um okay actually
uh people here prefer to see the board
on this uh
do you like the board projected there
there's also the recording of the video
so maybe they want to include well
actually i mean
if you yeah why don't you put the board
on the on all of them i guess people on
the sides can
okay so
uh the way this
square the story goes is that
you know it all starts with bypass like
matching we have this
hypothetic matching that edmonds was
interested in
and he invented this he asked this
question as a
some kind of linear algebraic
generalization of bipartite matching
and at the time he was not uh
aware of this but about a decade later
uh
so he suggested a symbolic determinant
for solving matching as you
many of you or all of you know and about
decades later
lovers noted that this can be solved in
bpp so that's a basic thing that we know
or in rp so
it's efficient and this derandomization
problem
became uh extremely
important it was a particular the
randomization problem
and it became very important for two
reasons
one is that it looked like something
about determinants but
over here valiants work
valiants work on the completeness of
determinant
for vp and later we'll talk about
permanent for vnp
so this result made it you know a
general polynomial identity test
and uh cabanas in palliative
may you know show that this the
randomization problem is sort of
universal if you
randomize it you'll get low bounds so
i want to talk about this uh a
non-commutative analog of this problem
and for that you know you have to try to
understand what's a non-community what
should be a non-commutative analog of
this problem
so let me maybe right
separate the body or two commutative
non-commutative
so we said that this is the question of
whether the determinant of l
is identically zero so what we can ask
about determinant
but there are lots of determinants in
the
in the non-commutative world so the
question may be which
determinant to choose uh that's one
problem we can look at other equivalent
versions of this question you can ask
whether this matrix is invertible
right that's a question here so is that
invertible
so over what
invertebrate well
are you all asleep it's
so over there over the national field
right over the
field of rational functions in this
variable that's the question
so you can ask if it's invertible here
but uh
over which so yeah
i mean what isn't that the same as
asking if the determinant is zero no
here in the non-commutative it's not in
the community
yeah so these are all equivalent these
are all equivalent ways and then you
wonder what's a non-commutative
analog so it's not clear whether you are
trying to invert this matrix if you are
non-commutative
we will talk about it yeah these are all
equivalent
but you can ask if n can be factorized
as i know k
times m well what did you write
i don't you know overreach over what
you may want to invert it but the
question is over what
um you know we can uh
try to just factor l
into narrow you know into narrow
matrices that's because again it's
equivalent just try to
and you can you have to ask over what
and again over
whatever field we are working on you
mean not invertible right
yeah so it's this yeah
yeah are they are they you know is it
yeah
yeah equivalent up to sign very good
yeah
so there is some field in the background
here
and of course this problem is in bpp
only if the field is loud
it's np hard otherwise but we are
talking about large fields
so again you can try to factor it here
and you can ask over what
and you can
what else can you do here
there are more equivalent ways of
looking at this uh
this problem well there is a you can ask
this describes a linear space
right this thing describes a linear
space of matrices
right this space you know there are the
linear functions here with some
coefficients so this l l can be written
as the sum
of x i a i where this guy is leaving
m of f so these are just constant
matrices and i'm just expressing the
this linear pencil it's called it is the
sum of
you know weighted sum with variables of
this
what no not monomials these are linear
functions
they are function
so what this is asking is the
does there exist a non-singular
singular matrix constant matrix
with some alpha i a i or alpha is in the
field
all right it's the same questions just
can you instantiate a non-singular
matrix
again equivalent but of course it
doesn't make
any sense here i mean would not the
non-commutativity will not show up
so it's not clear how to you know how to
generalize it and that's what
you know maybe we'll get to at the end
of the talk so let me
instead instead of waiting to the end of
the talk let me make sure i state some
result and then we'll see what we get to
so it turns out that this question
is so the the right form of this
question
uh bring this all this field into
play it is when you ask it
and i'll give you one formulation in a
second when you ask it
it becomes the the world problem
problem so
for sku fields i'll say what they are
so these guys are sitting on community
algebra
it becomes the question of what is the
you know whether these matrices
are in the nullcone
of some group action of the left right
group action
is the question in algebraic geometry
that actually was independently asked
because of gct it was us in algebraic
geometry
for their reasons and then it came up
again in the program of
marmalade's problem
and in quantity that is
the right way to formulate the problems
on the on the left
there is the corresponding these two
okay yeah there is a way to formulate it
which i'll give you one in a second
which is equivalent to these questions
from different fields
okay so these are equivalent
equivalent to asking in quantum
information theory whether a given
um completely
positive positive
quantum operator
operator
is what's called length decreasing
okay and let me give you
uh one formulation of this problem that
will turn out to be equivalent to all of
this and
it is sort of
range because the the place it arose
first
uh even before edmonds so badmons was
maybe the first to ask this question
explicitly as an algorithmic question
but people
studied it beforehand i know
well i can tell you references
uh when people try to ask
this question the communicative one so
people are interested not
just us people are interested in this
bit question
in linear algebra and method theory and
some in algebraic geometry they are
interested in
this question the commutative not just a
non-commutative one
and there they formulated
one
sufficient condition for this space to
be singular for the determinant to be
zero
okay what is this is called uh
l as the as the space of matrices has a
strong
strong subspace
what does it mean this is i think that
probably edmonds was aware of this this
is the
analog of the whole condition of whole
in a whole theorem for bipartite
matching that's what happens when you
lift it to
this symbolic uh matrix world it says
that
so l is a strong subspace if there
exists
subspaces let's say w and u and
dimension w is smaller than dimension of
u
and all the matrices ai shrink
used to w so and such that for all i
a i w a i u the fact that the
determinant equal to zero
is equivalent to that no non zero
no zero now this implies this
but not if and only if it's not true
actually let me give you an example
if it has a schwann subspace yeah so
this implies so
as a strong subspace is this definition
and it implies
that the determinant is zero yeah but
not the other way
it's not even only if there is no
duality theorem here
there's no duality theorem and in fact
i'll give you an example
when there is no duality theorem if you
want to see such a linear matrix
it's a very familiar one look at this
matrix
skew symmetric matrix x minus
x y minus y minus d
this matrix has
is is not full rank over commutative
variables
and it is full rank here in fact if i
replace the z
with ones it's very easy to see
because the determinant of this
is x y minus y x
okay but it has no strong subspace so to
see that it
it is full rank in the non-commutative
world it's a hard question
and this is what we are after checking
this condition
checking this condition is equivalent to
all these conditions that people were
interested in
now let me tell you it's not obvious
that this is decidable
this is in bpp it took years to
figure out that this is decidable and
the
result with the unkit and
rafael
is the
this is the deterministic polynomial
time algorithm for this problem
okay this is a deterministic polynomial
time algorithm for this problem over c
so if you give me integer matrices or
rational matrices so look at the input
there is a polynomial time algorithm in
there
the inputs is these matrices with the
polynomial time algorithm and the size
of the
matrices and the size of the entries
that tells you whether
it's for that's for non-commutative way
what if the input is l does it make
sense trust this
l is yeah the input is there so i give
you a basis for it
yeah i'm sorry give your basis forward i
ask whether it
so there's a polynomial time algorithm
now this polynomial time algorithm
is actually due to group it he just
didn't couldn't analyze
so he analyzed it in some special case
and
what what we do is basically give a full
analysis
and uh yeah and the
the main thing i think he was missing he
came from this point of view
the main thing he was missing is some
connection to this world
so let me tell you let's see so i have
15 minutes what can i tell you
uh i think i can tell you
some of the definitions
that come here uh but i
i want to i i talked about uh
some slaughtering cows
one uh
any questions so far so at least it's
clear what the
statement of the no i mean i don't know
is it it's not an an expression in
english i mean things that everybody
oh which which cow yeah which cow there
are several
yeah so there are several i was thinking
about and one is the
that in the non-commutative world so
there's a lot of
uh work in the non-commutative uh on
non-obesity arithmetic circuits
uh that i'm not going to have time to
survey but in this world
almost always the determinant you use is
a clearly determinant
as a it's a clearly determinant so let
me write down the
so let me just talk a little bit about
this world before
uh moving into the here's the
determinant
some of the old permutations
ah let's go what
matrix of variables
y1 sigma 1
y and
we think of it normally as a commutative
polynomial but
you can think of it as a non-commutative
polynomial of course then you have to
specify the order and you
can say well this is my order okay this
is my ordering of monomials
and this is called the kelly determinant
there are many other determinants for
the non-communicative world people
thought about it they had reasons to
think about it they are quantum
determinants so
uh various pascal determinants and so on
and people studied them but most of the
complexity results
are about this determinant and
let me mention just a couple not just
about this one but
so the most uh or the motivating
question
for me the past few years was
the problem of proving non-communicative
low bounds for circuits
non-nissan 30 years ago
proved that both the cayley or
and other clearly determinant
and permanent require
exponential size non-commutative
formulas
and let's open the question of circuits
it's also separated
exponentially formulas and circuits
and to date we have no circuit robots so
this is the main motivating
now uh in a paper with the
hubbas in the odaio
we were studying uh non-communicative
circuits and they had some approach but
in particular we gave
just an analog of variance results for
completeness of showing that
kelly permanent is complete for the
non-commutative analog of vnp
and the terminal is complete for
the analog of vp for the non-commutative
analog of vp
so these are completeness but you know
we use scaly
determinant for uh
from somehow non-commutative vp
which doesn't make sense because we
could unlike
so unlike in the communicative world
we don't know how we don't have an
algorithm for
click determinant
we don't have it so it's not a
completeness result just a hardness
result
and this was frustrating you can make
sense of completeness here but i won't
go into this
this question of kaylee
determinant came up in a completely
different
place in the algorithmic side uh
chen and the sinclair have a beautiful
uh
algorithm to try and approximate the
permanent of non-negative matrices
some people are familiar with it it
involves computing
the kelly determinant of some matrices
and we couldn't do this so
it doesn't make sense to have kelly
determinant here and eventually srikant
and his advisor having
explained it to us you know in the
non-commutative world you shouldn't
this is a bad idea to think about kelly
determine scaling determinant
and clearly permanent are the same thing
in a non-communicative way so this is
not the right notion of determinant
shouldn't be taken
you know we shouldn't take the terminals
of matrices like this in the
uh in the non-communicative world and
the question is what should you do
and the answer is actually this is again
something that mathematicians thought
about and uh
the answer is
what should be the answer what are the
terminals good for
they are good for solving systems of
linear equations right there they are
the cornerstone of linear algebra
because you know they encapsulate
matrix inverse so in the non-computative
case you have to study
matrix inverse so just
try to invert this and once you start
thinking about it you start wondering
inverting well okay
so pavel rubish and i
started investigating
circuits with division
inverting a matrix has to involve
division
circuits with division but
non-commutative circuits
you have to involve non-determine
circuits with division
and so once we slaughtered here the car
the car of
caylee determinant and move to matrix
inverse we have to slaughter
another car which is in the arithmetic
complexity world you know division can
be eliminated to us and thought of this
many many years ago
well in the non-communicative setting we
don't know that
we don't know that and it connects to
some of these questions so we studied
here in this paper when uh
division can be eliminated and we got to
we
basically got to this question basically
up to this question so let me talk a
little bit
about these uh uh
definitions of this uh problem a bit
more formally i i will
you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it it arises naturally
so let me tell you somehow well oh how
so here
what you need to do you need to
understand what does it mean to take
inverses in the non-commutative world so
you have to
you can you can look at the you know
let's say formulas expressions
like we use in the commutative world you
can
look at x plus y you know
times z and then you can take inverse
and so on right you are allowed to have
in division also right so just look at
expressions like this
and these are these
expressions they fill up the uh
what's called the localization of uh the
non-communicative algebra namely they're
just
the objects that you would like to have
when you are having division
uh over your non-commutative variables
and the question is whether it's a field
how to define this field and
you know there are
very basic questions and the person who
first defined what it means to have
a field a non-commutative field so take
the algebra of non-commutative elements
non-commutative polynomials and close
them under inverse
and he defined it and he said
well you know these are these are
rational expressions
first let me tell you a nice rational
expression
uh
it's the rational expression what is
peculiar about this rational expression
is that
it has nested inverses right like an
inverse then you take another inverse
in the commutative field you can
eliminate this i mean every object in
the
you know russian feed of rational
function is a range of two polynomials
always
is it true here or no
well actually this here it is
turns out that this is the x inverse
plus
x minus y this is called
identity very important the fundamental
theorem of projective geometry
but if i wrote here x plus
let's say y z inverse w
inverse then it cannot be simplified
and in fact there is a general theorem
of friends on our
saying that inverse height can be
arbitrary that's actually the connection
to formal language theory it's related
to those of
us who remember clini and schutzenberger
it's related to star height in formal
language
okay so it's really a complicated thing
this is a non-commutative formula
so how do you know whether two are
equivalent whether one is zero
uh the person will define that
so somehow i have to move these things
there
it did not get there
i'll tell you just a bit more about this
uh
i mean so in the 40s and 50s defined
the these fields i mean this field and
he said that in order to know whether
two rational expressions like this
is some r and this is t to know whether
they are the same
i mean you do something very natural you
evaluate them on matrices
just evaluate them on matrices so there
are expressions in many variables
you know so r is equivalent to to s
two rational expressions if
our you know vector of matrices is the
same
as as vector of matrix says well these
are
of course types of matrices of all sizes
and you have to be careful because there
are inversions and some matrices may not
be inversion so what you want this to
hold
is whenever the two expressions are
defined
okay so this is the definition of the
what's called the free skew field
and but still leaves the question this
world problem
our two expressions the same right it's
a
so i'm just reminding you what's a world
problem in general in
in in mathematics you have mathematical
objects you have
each object has many representations and
you ask whether two representations
are the same objects this is what
polynomial identity testing is
right so in the first field this is a
question
it was open and turns out to be i'm
cheating a bit is uh
i could define it's more precise this is
this problem
that is being salty
okay so let me tell you quickly
are the the two formulations in these
worlds are
and they turn out to be very relevant to
solving so is there like a natural bpp
algorithm here like switchbacks
no but although maybe i should mention
since you asked
maybe you want to ask me in the question
period
uh
it's a great question so forget rational
expressions talk about non-commutative
polynomials
you know polynomials non-communicative
polynomials is the more basic question
now some people are aware that there are
non-commutative identity tests like uh
rather than spill current others
which are very important but they are
white box
of course there are also some black box
results which i won't get into
but suppose you want something like
schwarz zipper this problem was
for polynomials so if r and s are
polynomials
this was solved in the in 1950
1950 thought a bpp algorithm amitsu
lewis
how did they solve it they said that if
you want to test that so here
there is no bound if i want to know
whether these guys are not not
equivalent it would be nice if i knew
that if these are expressions of size n
i have to go to
matrices of size i know and square 2 to
the n something
it's not clear which finite boundaries
that's why i said it's not clear that
it's decidable
but for polynomials they prove that for
n by n matrices sorry
if there are polynomials of degree
degree at most d then
um dimension of z
uh might as well be at most d over two
plus one
it should not go higher than this so
small matrixes are fine of course you
plug random ones and it works for
polynomials
for this we don't know so that's a very
good question
so let me have one more question so why
if you plug ground
once
random scalar as a polynomial like this
which is not zero will be zero
for all scalars right it cannot i mean
in non-commutative polynomials
there may be it may be identically zero
for matrices up to a certain
size but not higher when you plug in
matrices it becomes a community
polynomial
yeah well then when you plug matrices it
becomes a community that you can use
towards deeper length
yeah so let me just very quickly tell
you
the formulations from these
these two worlds this will be the easier
and
so what is a sorry i'm switching
context there are lots of contexts here
what is the completely positive operator
it's like a generalized measurement it's
a couple of matrices
just like that and it's an operator
on this on the space of matrices
so it this thing takes x
to this sum a i
x i
two matrices it's particularly
interested for interesting for them
where the x's are positive semi-definite
in fact of trace one they are density
matrices but you can define it like that
and the question is
so it's pretty well understood when
these operators
increase entropy and the question is way
well
you want them not to decrease the rank
so you want that it will not happens
xpsd
you you ask yourself this makes us a
decrease rank
if there is some matrix x such that
so let's call it yeah let me just say
um this is the operator l we called it l
if uh rank l of x is less than
rank of x
this is not good and you want to know
whether it happens or not this
equivalent to our question
this connection actually is not hard to
see
that this trunk subspace is the same as
this
it's not hard to see it's a projector on
the subspace basically
i should say what's what is hard to see
the connection of this to all of them i
forgot to mention in the
in the non-commutative world the person
that
did most of these connections is khan
who gave an alternative description of
the
frisco field and in particular proved
valiance completeness for determinant
long before valiant
but anyway uh
so there's a question in quantum theory
which is equivalent to our question
i will uh yeah i uh i have to finish so
i can
take a few minutes just to tell you what
this uh or you can ask me i
i think i have to finish so just to be
polite let me
uh yeah
what
i should say invariant theory so there
was this whole semester here
devoted to this connection of arithmetic
complexity and the invariant theory
algebraic geometry representation theory
and very briefly what these guys study
let me do it here and then it will be
bigger and clearer
they study group actions
so they study groups acting on vector
spaces so g
acts
vectors and when you have an action so
this v
you can you can always think of it from
x f to the n uh when you have this
action you can think of uh
g also acting on polynomials
it just acts on the coordinates linear
transformations on the code and i saw
you have an action on polynomials and
the question is what are the invariant
polynomials so in variance so
this f of x g
are those invariant polynomials so p
such that invariant
under the action
oh just an example that you are all
familiar with
if g is a symmetric group which are the
environment polynomials
symmetric polynomials right so these are
so these are symmetric polynomials
and it turns out that
uh very base two very basic uh
actions that are studied in algebraic
geometry and also in
in gct are the actions of matrix groups
on tuples of matrices
and this go back to the 19th century one
is simultaneous
so in both cases we have so sln or slm
square so it's so just the uh
invertible matrices of determinant one
how do matrices like this like a matrix
b
acts on a tuple a one up to a
n it sends it to b a
1 b inverse so just simultaneous
conjugation
so this is a that's one group action
and here
the same way
okay so these groups of invertible
matrices acts on couple of matrices by
simultaneous conjugation here pairs of
matrices arced by
left multiplying from the left and from
the right
in all of them you are trying to
understand what are the
invariant polynomials but these are
infinitely many
so what you want to know is you know a
finite basis for this
the fact that there is a finite basis
and a non-trivial fact that silbert's
uh crm there's always a finite
generating set
of the invariants here and you're trying
to
you know characterize them say what
their degrees are and so on
uh this is extremely well understood
this is relatively recently
very well understood and also led to
some work uh
connecting to the randomizations also
know the forbes spiritual
uh paper answering marmalade's question
uh we understand this even better than
the algebraic geometers
dreamed of and finally this section why
is it relevant to us
it's relevant to us because if i give
you a couple of matrices and i ask
whether they have a strong subspace or
in any of the other formulation
formulations of this question it's clear
that this question is invariant
under the left right action right if i
change basis from the left and from the
right
this question remains the same it has
full non-commutative rank if it has for
non-communicative rank when i change
this matrix as my left and right
action so
uh
i this question it why can't we see that
how come i don't see that
i mean it won't matter whether which
side you put the u on
a i times u or u yeah so it will just
change what this uh
the question is whether they're
invertible matrices so
the question is whether there exists
these two subspaces they will exist you
just change these basis with
b and c as long as you use the same b
on all the ai's and the same c on the
right side on all the eyes
sorry maybe i didn't understand your
question
it's it's uh okay this question is
invariant under this action and in
particular
whether a couple of matrices uh
you know has has this property turns out
to be the same question as asking
whether
a couple of matrices satisfies is a
common zero of all invariant polynomials
this is a narcon of
of this action so whether it satisfies
all the invariant polynomials
so that's another uh
another way to ask this question and
people here studied bounds on the size
of
on the degree of the basis for these
environment polynomials
these sizes are exactly the size well
maybe i should
the invariant polynomial 0 are simply
all
polynomials of the form should i write
it
right here all polynomials of the form
the determinant of the sum of
x y
in other words plugging matrices
plugging large matrices
into the non-communicative variables
that we have and the question is how
large matrices you need to plug
so that you will recognize that
something like this happens so in some
sense it's a reduction
of the non-commu of the
non-commutative question to the
communicative question in a much larger
space
the question is how large should you go
it turns out that the best bounds are
exponential
and despite the fact that they are
exponential then this
what happens for polynomials doesn't
happen for rational functions
you know there is an analysis you can do
and use this result this exponential
bound to get a polynomial time algorithm
so now i really stop and you can ask me
even more questions i
i know it was very impressionistic this
talk but
that's what it is
i didn't quite get the bottom line so
you have the the one problem above
that's definitely empty
yeah then the three below i wasn't here
are you showing that that's equivalent
to that problem and so they're all empty
it's one they're just equivalent to each
other they are all equivalent sorry
russell thank you
they are all equivalent these
equivalences were known
were known many due to the non-trivial
ones are due to con
and some are easy that other people
figured out
and they are also yeah and then you get
a non-cumulative lower bound from this
yeah i wish so
there is a very obvious way
in fact we thought we we know it's right
you just apply cabanas in palliative why
not i mean
the self-reducibility works
right so what i didn't mention
is that matrix inverse
unlike kaylee determinant has
small non-commutative circuits this is
something that i i should have said
right so why why is it good for
completeness using matrix inverse as
opposed to kelly determinant matrix
inverse
in the non-commutative in
non-commutative algebra has a
simple circuit you just you know all you
have to do is do it for two by two
matrices and then
recurse so because they are good
they are small non-communicative
matrices for matrix inverse and we can
test this we can
really test whenever we are inverting a
matrix that it has an inverse
we can apply a result and get a lower
bound
which is not conditional because we have
a deterministic pid
this is great only that this is a
non-commutative circuit
and we don't know um
how do i say it you don't get the lower
bound for the same problem we don't get
the lower bound for the same problem we
need to
ask the question about matrices as
opposed to scalars
so we can we can't apply what you would
like to do is
like in your case you eventually apply
your arithmetic circuits
to boolean matrices right to integer
matrices
you would like to apply the
noncommutative circuit to integer
matrices and they may it may be
identically zero on
all integer matrices or on constant
scalars matrices so you cannot yeah it
just doesn't work so this is this
chasing low bounce within
cashity
you mentioned that uh non-commutative
case but
kelly determinant is equivalent to
locally permanent
could you say a little bit more uh what
this means yeah so
there are several results uh the first
result of uh
avenues universal was in the context of
uh
uh arithmetic branch non-communicative
arithmetic branch
programs they saw they showed that if
you have a non-communicative arithmetic
branching program for
kelly determinants you can build from it
a
slightly larger non-communicative
automatic branching program for kaylee
permanent
so in other words solving it
non-commutatively for determinants you
can do it
and then in a later paper with chin and
sinclair they actually
characterize much better you know even
over which algebras
they are equivalent even all over
quaternions
it's like it's even over quaternions
they are
they are the same so it's really well
understood
non-commutative world the terminal is as
hard as burma
but quaternions was done by plaza
actually yeah